more riots just days before
the 2020 presidential election we're
getting some breaking news this happened
overnight
30 philadelphia police officers
were injured during an hours-long blm
riot in philadelphia what prompted the
riot well by now i'm sure you can guess
there was
a force involved there was an officer
involved killing
what are the circumstances of the
killing was it some innocent man
who was just minding his own business
you know doodling on a sheet of doing an
oil painting and
and watching a sunset no he was
approaching cops
with a knife the guy was wielding a
knife he was demonstrating force
so the cops responded in kind cut to
hours and hours of riots which involved
one female police officer
getting run over which involved zillions
and zillions of people
pouring out into the streets and 29
other cops
getting injured take a listen
just a cacophony just a mayhem and
the question comes why now why in this
case
the incident itself doesn't seem to
justify any kind of riot or protest for
that matter
but that's not what it's about now any
use of officer force
is simply a signal for all of the
radicals to pour out into the street
and overthrow the system you can expect
a whole lot more of that
if joe biden gets elected president you
remember cnn was saying guys we got to
stop the riots
after weeks and weeks of defending the
rights they said we got to stop the
riots they're showing up in the polls
well if there's going to be any silver
lining to this storm cloud let's hope it
shows up in the polls
on november 3rd i'm michael knowles this
the michael knolls show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from eric
thompson
if you're not on the take then you ain't
joe biden
that's a nice way to switch
the joe biden claim that if you don't
know who you're voting for you ain't
black if you're not on the take you
ain't joe biden that guy
has of course been on the take you know
some people have raised this issue
that the republican messaging is getting
stale
we called hillary a crook and we're
calling joe biden a crook
and so that's just not plausible what
are you talking about of course it is
those two politicians have been in the
business for a very very long time
and we have evidence that they have sold
their influence
hillary and biden are practically the
same exact politician
hillary is a little more detestable just
on television and on the campaign trail
joe biden's a little more likable old
folksy uncle joe joe from scranton or
wherever he says he's from this week
but beyond that they're essentially the
same person they've enriched themselves
in public service they've entered into a
lot of shady deals with a lot of foreign
actors
and now they're running for president
because it's their turn there are some
genuine ideologues
on the left but in terms of the blow in
the wind no principles
corrupt politicians hillary and biden
basically
the same thing they they figured out
certainly how to enrich themselves by
the way if you want to figure out how
you can enrich yourself
you got to check out acre it's real it's
a way
to invest that allows you to invest
in gold without having a ton of cash at
your disposal right now
this has always been an issue with
investing in gold you say okay i'd like
to i'd like to buy some gold
but i but i don't have enough money to
go and buy a gold bar you know that's
just
too expensive well what's great is with
with the price of gold skyrocketing
lately
there's a new way you can buy gold
through a company called acre what acre
lets you do
is subscribe to gold bars for as little
as thirty dollars per month
but michael gold costs more than thirty
dollars per bar right i know so what you
do is you pay
each month once your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they will discretely
ship acre gold to your house it's a
really great idea
it's a great way to also put you on a
regimented plan so that you know
everyone has the good idea to invest but
often people don't follow the discipline
to actually do it
just 30 a month and then it adds up and
adds up and adds up and once
it hits the price of the actual gold
they will discretely shift the physical
gold too i think it's a terrific idea
great way to get involved in investing
in physical gold
acre also just recently introduced their
new hundred dollar per month
subscription
for their five gram gold bar i myself
have invested in precious metals
and i really have enjoyed that
experience get
acre gold.com that's the website go to
getacregold.com
knowles start investing in physical gold
today make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
that sounds pretty great
to qualify for that tweeter post why you
should be the recipient mention
at get underscore acre that is getacre
gold.com
knowles thank you akergold for
supporting our show
other big news yesterday we have a new
supreme court justice
amy coney barrett she was confirmed
yesterday in the senate
and then president trump not wasting any
time whatsoever
decides to have the swearing-in ceremony
that night
at the white house clarence thomas came
down from the court
to swear in j then judge now
justice amy barrett take a listen
barrett i solemnly swear that i will
support
and defend the constitution of the
united states
that i will support and defend the
constitution of the united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
against all enemies
foreign and domestic that i will bear
true faith and allegiance to the same
that i will bear
true faith and allegiance to the same
that i take this obligation freely
that i take this obligation freely
without any
mental reservation without any mental
reservation
or purpose of evasion or purpose of
evasion
and that i will well and faithfully
that i will well and faithfully
discharge
the duties of the office from which i'm
about to end
the duties of the office on which i am
about to enter
so help me god so help me god
all right wonderful news i love that
president trump jumped on this
nomination i love
that the senate pushed the nomination
through and i love that he didn't waste
even 12 hours waiting to do it this
morning for the swearing-in ceremony
they did it last night i love that
clarence thomas was the one to do it
clarence thomas you know the the old
school
conservative the old school originalist
on the court
absolutely love everything about that
some conservatives though i think are
reacting in a way that is
not so helpful and i don't listen i get
that there is a political
optics aspect to all of this so
sometimes conservatives get carried away
with this but there was a member of the
trump campaign who tweeted out
a black conservative supreme court
justice swearing in a female
conservative supreme court justice
epic i thought
what's epic about that i
i like that clarence thomas is swearing
in amy barrett
that's pretty epic i like that the
confirmation has happened so quickly
that's pretty epic
i like various attributes of these two
people clarence thomas's story
what we know about amy berry you know
the seven kids and all that i think
that's all epic
why is it epic that a black guy swears
in a woman
why should i care why should i care
about that i think what conservatives
often do
is we get so excited when we've got
a woman to be sworn in and that and it's
she's being sworn in by a man
a black guy that we want to prove to the
left
that we're not misogynists and we're not
racial bigots and we're
we want to we're so excited to prove
that to them that we focus
on race and sex as though they were
very top priority political categories
and we think yeah take that liberals see
we're not racist and sexist
they don't they one they don't believe
that we're not racist and sexist
but even if they did they don't care
it's not going to persuade them of
anything at all
and actually what it does is just buy
into their stupid view of politics
that says that we need to have a woman
forget who the woman is we just need a
woman
we need to have a black guy doing not
forget who the black guy is we just need
to have a black guy
and i just don't care
when i say that i don't care that amy
barrett's a woman or that clarence
thomas is a black guy
i know what it sounds like is i don't i
don't think any less of amy barrett
because she's a woman or i don't think
that's not what i'm saying what i'm
actually saying is
i could not possibly care any less
that republicans put a woman on the
court this time
if they had put a man on the court
wouldn't wouldn't change my opinion at
all
as long as the man were a solid judge i
couldn't possibly care less
that republicans put a black guy on the
court if they put a white guy in the
court or a hispanic guy on the court or
an asian guy in the court or whatever
guy in the court
it would not make me happier wouldn't
make me
sadder wouldn't make it wouldn't change
my opinion i just think
we need to stop giving the left their
premise here on on these racial and
sexual questions i know we think we're
like ah now we're going to prove to them
that we're not bigots
you're not gonna prove that to them and
who cares i don't care what they think
i do not care what the left thinks of me
especially on racial
and sexual quest questions they have no
credibility whatsoever
and i'm very i'm very pleased that we
have this judge but i i don't want to
play
according to their rules i want the
court to operate well which by the way
it will not
if joe biden gets elected joe biden was
just asked
thankfully finally by a reporter what do
you think of
uh term limits on the supreme court what
do you think of packing the supreme
court what do you think of this and that
all these various changes and joe biden
we were talking about this yesterday he
can't give a straight answer on anything
whenever he gives a straight answer puts
him in a tough position
so he talks out of both sides of his
mouth
you mentioned just a minute ago there
that as part of your commission you
would look at how long justices serve on
the court does that mean that you're
open to term limits but no no
there is a question about whether or not
it's a lifetime appointment
i'm not going to attempt to change that
at all there's some literature
among councils of scholars about the
possibility of going from one court to
another court
not just always staying the whole time
on the supreme court but i have made no
judgment my word
my words have made no judgment they're
just a group of
serious constitutional scholars have a
number of ideas
how we should proceed from this point on
and uh
that's what we're going to be doing i'm
going to give them a 180 days god
willing if i'm elected
from the time i'm sworn in to be able to
make such a recommendation
absolutely not we are not going to have
term limits for the supreme court but we
might take them off the supreme court
you know what you know i'm no
constitutional expert that sounds like a
term limit to me
if you're saying no we're not going to
limit the amount of time that these
judges can sit on the supreme court
but we might after a certain period of
time move them to a different court that
is effectively a term limit so what joe
is doing here
is what he does all the time which is
absolutely i support up but
and and by supporting up what i mean is
i support down yeah i totally support
east
east is what i support i totally can get
behind east
and that means i support west i mean he
always does this with these
these opposite issues so he's leaving
himself open
he doesn't know what he believes he's
never known what he believes he believes
whatever is popular
and he convinces himself to believe that
and unfortunately right now what's
popular is
packing the court what's popular is term
limiting conservatives in particular
what's popular is
politicizing the court more so than it
already is
and so joe's going to go along with it
if he gets elected there's no doubt in
my mind
i don't think joe cares one way or the
other just like i don't care about the
race or sex of the supreme court justice
one way or the other
i certainly think joe does not care
whether they pack the court whether they
don't pack the court he just wants to be
the president
and have a post office named after him
that's all he wants the actual
government that can be left
to somebody else he gets very confused
he we know that he gets very confused it
seems though he's got a pretty good
chance of becoming president because
the democrats are committing voter fraud
you don't need to take my word for it
joe admitted it himself secondly
we're in a situation where we have put
together
and you guys did it for our administer
the president obama's administration
before this we have put together i think
the most
extensive and inclusive voter fraud
organization in the history of american
politics
couldn't have put it better myself i
guess joe is honest every once in a
while
you know that guy he normally talks out
of both sides of his mouth but there
there was no other side
he just said listen i gotta thank you
guys you helped us do it under obama
you know wish it worked better under
obama but you've helped us put together
the most inclusive
wonderful greatest voter fraud apparatus
in american history that's probably true
i have to agree with fact check true
watch they're gonna
this is what's gonna happen the fact
checking websites are going to
fact check me just repeating joe biden's
words and they're gonna say that i'm
lying and he's telling the truth
wait for it i promise you maybe unless
they're watching this show maybe then
they won't he gets very confused issue
maybe he wanted to say voter fraud
prevention
program but that's not what he said
that's a freudian slip i think is what
you'd call it that's where you say one
thing but me and your mother joe biden
obviously fell into that
he also gets confused about very
personal matters so
in the same interview he was he was
talking about his grandchildren
and he misstated how many grandchildren
he has
you guys have such an enormous following
not only with my children my grown
children but my
five grandchildren who range in age from
27 to uh to 14.
no that's not true 16. she'd be very
upset i said
14. that's not true either he actually
doesn't have five grandchildren he has
seven grandchildren and they don't
range down to age 14 they range down to
age two
or even even a little bit younger maybe
he's got these two new kids from hunter
biden
one an illegitimate child with his his
mistress
one of his mistresses and then the other
one with his new wife
born almost around the same time now you
might say well joe's just getting
confused i don't think joe's getting
confused here i don't think joe forgot
those grandkids i think joe is choosing
not to acknowledge them because
he's done this a number of times he's
been called out for it hunter biden
is the number one scandal in his
presidential campaign i don't think joe
just forgot
that joe bye that hunter biden has these
two kids
and and this is where i think good old
nice grant joe
he's just a good fella he's just a nice
guy i think that breaks down because i
think joe is choosing not to acknowledge
two of his own grandkids
and i think that's a very cruel wrong
immoral thing to do
and i think if you're those kids and you
grow up and you know you've got a
schmuck dad
and you know you come from this very
powerful you know long-standing
washington political family and your
grandpa
joe biden refused to acknowledge you i
think that's going to make you feel
pretty bad
i think that's going to give you some
problems down the line
and i think joe biden is doing it
intentionally because he doesn't want to
acknowledge
that he's got these extra kids and it's
a very very mean
cruel thing to do and no one's held him
to account for it even the
conservatives as far as i can tell don't
hold him to account what the
conservatives often do is they'll say
haha joe
you don't forget those two extra kids
that were born at a wedlock that
ha ha you know it's because hunter biden
slept with a stripper and you know use
it as a way to basically attack hunter
biden
just think about it from the kids
perspective
imagine you if you didn't know your
grandfather if your grandfather refused
to acknowledge you you'd probably feel
pretty bad about that and joe biden
should feel bad about that because what
he's doing is very wrong
he does a lot of things that are very
wrong but then he plays it off because
he's got that big grinning
smile those big fake teeth and he smacks
you on the back and he says oh hey there
corn pop what's going on malarkey come
on man
i don't think you can come on man that
come on man acknowledge your grandkids
he does get confused though joe biden
does get confused
such as when he forgets who the
president of the united states is uh joe
biden was doing
an interview and he appeared to think
that the president
is named george this is the most
consequent not because i'm running
but because who i'm running against
that's the most consequential election
uh in a long long long time
and the character of the country in my
view is literally on the ballot
what kind of country we're going to be
four more years of george
georgia he uh is gonna find ourselves in
a position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
four more years of george uh of george
uh
well if we uh uh uh so right now
some people think that joe biden
was confused and thought that george w
bush or george h.w bush
was still president or george washington
i don't know he was around for all three
as far as i can tell
that's one theory he confused the
president it's not donald trump he
thinks it's george bush
the other theory is he was talking to
george lopez george lopez the
the actor was interviewing him and so he
got he just
repeated george lopez's name and then
i have a third theory which nobody's
talking about so the first theory sounds
the most plausible because there there's
he just ran right into it right he said
if we have four more years of george
uh of george uh so there was no break it
wasn't
if we have four more years comma george
if we have four more years of this
george if we have four more years of
donald
george it wasn't that he just ran right
into it we have four more years of
george so
there might be something to that idea
that he still thinks george bush is the
president
if he were talking to george there there
would be a george lopez there would be a
like a comma in there or it might be the
case that sometimes his brain just gets
so fried that he just kind of
very quickly shifts to another topic
when he can't finish his own sentence so
maybe there's a possibility there
what i think was happening is his his
brain just popped a little bit like it
usually does it just kind of
overheated and he was trying to buy time
because he couldn't remember the name of
the president
okay i think that's the most charitable
most
uh conservative read of this is
he forgot donald trump's name and so he
said the first name that popped into his
head maybe he was thinking of george
bush maybe he was thinking about george
lopez maybe he was thinking about george
of the jungle
and he just said we have four more years
george george
trump i don't even know if he got to
trump
either way any of those three options
not good you've got a guy who is going
to be the
leader of the free world don't forget
president of the united states isn't
even just the president of the united
states that would be enough
but he's the leader of the free world
the american election is the global
election at least for the west but even
beyond the west
when ruth ginsburg died there was
mourning in
other countries in south america people
were talking about how awful it was that
there was the death of this judge
okay there are debates over the american
supreme court in europe i mean
that that shows you the kind of extent
of the american empire and this guy
his brain doesn't work very well not
a good situation to be in so what does
that mean does that mean that kamala
harris is going to be
the president the real president the
shadow president is going to be some
other staffer i don't know
what i do know though is that if biden
can't can't make the long run
kamala harris isn't going to be much
better kamala just did a long series of
interviews
incredibly despite how bad biden is
she's almost as bad she was asked the
question how left wing are you because
kamala harris has been considered one of
if not the single most left-wing member
of the united states senate she was
asked about this on 60 minutes
didn't have much of an answer you're
very different
in the policies that you've supported in
the past you're considered the most
liberal united states senator i
somebody said that and it actually was
mike pence on the debate stage
but yeah well actually the non-partisan
gov track has rated you as the most
liberal senator you supported the green
new deal you supported medicare for all
you've supported legalizing marijuana
oh that awkward laugh went away real
quick didn't it
she always does it she always goes for
this really
obviously disingenuous laugh when she
has no answer
but she didn't even get to the laugh
quick enough so you're the most liberal
member of the senate
no no pence said that no i was pence
right always trying to shift
off the blame always trying to avoid the
question there was pence that was pence
and then this woman on 60 minutes to her
credit she goes
no no that was like every independent
adjudicator of these questions i
actually said that you're the but by
your voting record you're the most
liberal senator
and then you just see that hahaha
artificial laugh just sort of
slowly melt into this no
i one thing that i was actually
surprised about with kamala harris
is how untalented she is i
i did believe that she was a talented
politician going you know she
attorney general to california senator
she's relatively young
she's me so i just thought she must be
talented but i hadn't seen that much of
her
and she's not she's really bad at this
she might she might be the most liberal
senator she might be the least talented
member even macy hirono who talk about
people's brains not working that well
at least maisie hirono has some
smoothness to her
rhetorical delivery kamala harris has
nothing it's so stilted and awkward and
the laughing
so this interviewer on 60 minutes pushes
her a little further she says so what's
your
what's your world view kamala are you a
socialist you progressive are you left
are you what what are you
same thing not much of an answer what i
will do and i promise you this
and this is what joe wants me to do this
was part of our deal
i will always share with him my lived
experience as it relates to any issue
that we confront and i promised joe that
i will give him that perspective and
always be honest with him
and is that a socialist or progressive
perspective no
no it is the perspective of of a woman
who grew up a a black child in america
who was also a prosecutor who also has a
mother who arrived here at the age of 19
from india who also you know
likes hip-hop what do you want to know
i don't know i want to know anything of
substance other than all that stupid
completely irrelevant nonsense that you
just spouted out
because you want to hide your political
views that's a totally fair question
the woman is ranked the most left-wing
member of the u.s senate she
co-sponsored the green new deal
which is communism it's just communism
it's just
a nationalization of major industries
including energy
taking away virtually all energy out of
the private sector
a redistribution of wealth under the
likes of which we've never
seen we never saw in the soviet union a
a complete
raising of people's homes actually
knocking down their homes to make them
energy efficient rebuilding every home
in america in 10 years yeah
pretty radical stuff so i just want to
know kamala do you agree with that
she goes oh no so what's your
perspective and she gets so nervous
you know sounds like she's going to cry
she did this during the mike pence
debate too
and then what does she go to what's your
perspective kamala we
you want us to take you seriously you
want to be treated like a serious
politician okay
what are your views what does she go she
says i'm
i'm black okay
doesn't doesn't tell me about your views
that's tells me about your skin color
which i can see
because i have eyes i i i'm a woman
uh-huh i can also see that kamala
darn those two victim groups didn't do
me any good all right let me try again
my mom's an immigrant okay not by the
way not a victim group your mom chose to
come here so that's
if anything that's kind of like a point
against you right in terms of the victim
hierarchy because
you entered this country or your family
entered this country freely of their own
volition anything else
ah okay the race thing didn't work and
the woman thing didn't work and the
immigrant thing didn't work
i like hip-hop so like first of all no
you don't you also don't like hip-hop
she did this early on in the campaign
when she was running for president for
five minutes before she was the first
one out of the race
and she she said oh yeah she was on some
radio show and she was pandering and she
said
i love hip-hop oh yeah i used to smoke
big fat doobies you know when i was in
college and i'd listen to
snoop diggity doo dog and you know i'd
listen to whatever
i don't know tupac and you'd say okay i
don't believe that for a second but let
me just google
oh right yeah their albums didn't come
out until you were out of college
so that's a very easily checked
lie she said so all of those things
who cares this is why we can't take her
seriously because she won't take herself
seriously
if you're asked a question as a
politician what are your views on
political issues
you better have an answer that's the
basic requirement is to have
views on political issues if you want to
be a politician
and if you're if your only answer is i'm
well i'm italian i'm a man
okay cool cool man
that's great we're gonna go back to the
other guy now but neither kamala
nor joe biden can give an answer on
anything
because they are both empty suit
politicians and they just blow whichever
way the wind blows so one day kamala is
going to be a socialist okay because
that's how the wind's been blowing for
much of her career
if it were the 90s again you know it was
94 again she'd probably be just like
bill clinton and joe biden actually and
blow back and oh i'm a centrist i'm what
she doesn't want she just wants to be
the vice president in any case she's not
ready for
prime time why did biden pick her when
you when you listen to this interview
you just think oh my god is there nobody
in the country
that could do this better maybe there
isn't but the reason he picked her by
his
own explanation is because she's a black
woman
that's what he said he said before he
ever thought of kamala harris pray
before he knew her name
he said i am going to pick a black woman
a woman of color
to be my vice presidential running mate
and
he then committed to to it being a black
woman and in the democrat there were
plenty of uh republican black women
actually
good choices but uh in the democratic
party there weren't that many at the
national level who could run
so he was basically down to kamala
harris
who you know is not that great but
whatever she's kind of nothing
then susan rice who was the fall man for
benghazi
and who's deeply implicated in the 2016
obama corruption scandal so that
probably wasn't going to work
and karen bass who's a communist she's
that of a congressional black caucus
i spoke to her on alex michaelson's show
on fox over here
she's like an actual communist who has
openly supported communist
politicians and communist movements so
that probably wasn't going to work
either so kamala's the least bad option
but there were better options it's just
that joe biden because he played into
this stupid race and sex game
backed himself into a corner and now
he's got a very untalented running mate
a weak running mate who
only recommends herself the only way
that she recommends herself
is by her race and sex even the
genuine ideologues in the democratic
party people like aoc
have the same problem she sent out one
of the silliest most frivolous tweets
she's ever sent out which i know is
saying quite a lot we'll get to it in a
second but you know the presidential
election
is almost here we have a fabulous day of
programming for you
our live stream starts on tuesday
november 3rd that's election day
you know if you're a republican if
you're a democrat well maybe wait until
wednesday but you know
uh tuesday november 3rd 3 p.m eastern 12
p.m pacific
featuring special guests live interviews
and more leading up to a very special
episode of backstage
where we will be covering the results
with you in real time and even better
join daily wire now
get 25 off with code election
so that you can watch all of our
election coverage live on our apple tv
and roku app
so watch the election with us at
dailywire.com and get 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you sign up today head on
over to daily wire we'll be right back
with a lot more
even aoc an actual socialist
valid leftist ideologue
has this same problem that we're seeing
here
come from the left but some
right-wingers play into it which is just
always going back
to race and sex as though that's the
most interesting thing about you as
though that's interesting at all really
she was whining the other night because
someone it was the president referenced
aoc
so he's been aoc plus three so aoc plus
three is the other members of the squad
who are all these leftists who hate
america
and aoc tweets out i wonder if
republicans understand how much they
advertise their disrespective women in
debates
when they consistently call women
members of congress by nicknames or
first names
while using titles and last names when
referring to men
of equal stature women notice it conveys
a lot so first pause right there
in the same debate where where president
trump refers to aoc as aoc
he refers to joe biden as joe and joe
and and aoc are not of equal stature joe
whether we like it or not is of a much
higher stature than aoc
joe biden is a former united states
senator and former vice president of the
united states
aoc is a member of congress
lbj once described the difference
between the senate and the house
as the difference between chicken salad
and chicken
excrement oh yeah he used more colorful
language
they're not of equal stature but trump
still refers to
joe biden as joe anyway she goes on
aoc is a name given to me by my
community and the people
you can y'all can call me aoc government
colleagues referring to each other in a
public or professional context
aka who don't know me like that should
refer to their peers as congresswoman
representative etc basic respect 101
lady get
over yourself oh my gosh you're a you're
a member of the house of representatives
that is the lowest office you can
possibly have in the federal government
if i did somehow find myself in the
house of representatives if i did find
myself as a member of congress
i would hide that fact i would ask to be
referred to as
mr knowles or michael i would not
advertise
that members of congress members of the
house of representatives are some of the
least
popular people in the entire country
there are years where diseases are more
popular than members of the house of
representatives
get over yourself by the way do you know
where trump might have
heard this nickname aoc you know where
he might have heard it from your twitter
handle which is aoc
there are initials there's nothing
bigoted about initials
but the only thing that this woman can
even say to recommend herself is
i'm a woman i'm a woman that's why
you're talking to me
because what because nobody ever
referred to
barack nobody ever referred to bill
clinton called bill clinton bubba
is that disrespectful what about
what about joe we talked about joe
sleepy joe little marco
what about any of those low energy jeb
is that disrespectful
i get maybe those actually are
disrespectful aoc
is not this cult because obviously this
is a very stupid tweet of hers
but listen to what is beneath it she's
saying
some people can refer to me by that and
it's respectful
but other people cannot refer to me by
that name because it's disrespectful
and i'm not even going to tell you the
objective criteria
for who can refer to me as aoc right she
says it's
community and the people what is that
it's so subjective
and there's no way to know until you say
it there's no way to know who is allowed
to call her aoc
and who is not allowed to call her aoc
because
at the very bottom at the very most
extreme
basic level of this ideology
is a denial or dismissal of objective
reality
this is that has always been at the
basis of that marxism progressivism the
various idiot leftist ideologies that
have cropped up over the last 150 years
it's this denial of reality we will
change human nature we will change
that the world is no longer governed by
fixed laws we're in the world of
evolution we're in the world
of transforming human nature and
progressing toward utopia that's what
obviously aoc doesn't know any of this
because she's never cracked the spine of
any book that would even suggest these
things but that is at the basis of what
she's learned
essentially through slogans we can
change the world we can change objective
reality
but that cult of subjectivism and
identity politics is maddening i don't
mean
it makes you mad and angry i mean i mean
it makes you mad in the sense that makes
you crazy
makes you lose your mind because there's
nothing to
to rely on anymore in the in the
objective world
there's a woman who just went viral on
this point a woman who
posted a tick tock video so many
problems begin with posting tick tock
videos she posted a tick talk video
about how she was talking to her father
and
convinced him to vote for joe biden just
take a listen she opens this is my 55
year old conservative dad she's holding
up little cards
has never voted democrat in his life
he's
dying of aplastic anemia
we've had some intense exchanges yeah
presumably
about him voting for trump this year
what a what a way to waste time
with your dad who's dying which has been
painful since we'll
almost certainly lose him in the next
few weeks and months
he has six daughters who love him dearly
yesterday he was
so excited to tell me he just voted for
biden harris 2020
for exclamation points because
it matters to my girls
and my girls matter to me
vote for the guy who respects women
if my very republican dad can
so can you i think i'm going to vote for
the guy
who is supported by people who respect
their parents
their dying parents this woman is sick
she has got a sickness
that a lot of people i think have right
now in this culture
almost exclusively on the left can you
imagine this she says
my dad is dying how sad is that he's
dying of a
disease that i believe makes it
difficult for your blood to carry oxygen
i think that's what aplastic anemia is
and we're having these intense exchanges
yeah of course you would that's what you
do
when your parent is dying in these very
intense moments it's a terribly sad
time and the intense exchanges are about
donald trump
donald trump could you imagine wasting
your precious remaining moments with
your parents
on donald trump or any politician for
that matter
how sick how warped does your head have
to be and then
to exert all this emotional manipulation
on a dying man your dying father
to vote for joe biden who gives a damn
who cares
joe biden doesn't even care some days
you don't even know he's running for
president
joe biden who doesn't believe in a thing
that's it that's that's what you want
the last moments to be
sick stuff now what's really this
obviously isn't about joe biden because
or come out kamala harris for that
matter because
neither of them have any beliefs they're
the least inspiring politicians
ever just about what this is
is a religious cult
progressivism leftism secular liberalism
what everyone called
is a religious cult because a more
typical reaction if a parent or a loved
one is dying
is to consider eternal questions where
do we go after we die what is this life
about what am i made for what is what is
is there something more than this life
try to get right with god
if you do have a faith you'd like to
nudge
your friends and family members over to
that faith
maybe get baptized maybe if you're
already baptized confess your sins
receive the eucharist
receive the sacraments get right with
god
and that's what this woman i think is
doing too she's saying get right with
god but but in the cult of secular
liberalism
that the sacrament is voting for this
crook joe biden
that's the sacrament is voting it's why
you have to vote vote or die
we might say receive the sacraments or
die in the in the eternal life what
they're saying
vote or die you have to vote why vote it
doesn't it's fine
my life will go on if i don't vote if i
didn't know anything about the issues i
it would be better if i didn't vote
but you have to this is the last dad i
know we've only got a few moments left
vote for joe biden how
sad how deeply sad is that for this
woman
for her family for the country
very sad stuff very crazy stuff you
should not be doing that
speaking of women speaking of crazy
stuff
tampax the women's hygiene company
just tweeted out fact
not all women have periods that's true
menopause pre-prepubescent
also a fact not all people with periods
are women
there you lose me uh i was with you i
was trying to give you the benefit of
that there you lose me
let's celebrate the diversity of all
people who bleed
myth busting period truths
trans is beautiful so first of all i
guess they thought
this was referring to transgenderism you
know if a
a woman pretends to be a man
that obviously she could still uh
menstruate and therefore
if you if you believe that a woman can
just become a man by saying so
then a man can menstruate you know the
the
the little leap of logic that's going on
here that isn't totally kosher namely
that you can just become the other sex
by wishing it so
but also this i like the idea of this
phrase
people who bleed we've taken
woman lady
even some sort of disparaging terms for
women broad
dame whatever we've taken different
words to mean woman
and we have taken out all of their
vividness we've taken out all of the
color we've taken out all of
the beauty or you know
graphic imagery we've taken it all out
we've just made it so clinical people
who bleed
well that's everybody i bleed not that
way but i do bleed
if you cut me do i not bleed if i'd you
know
now i'm evoking my inner shakespeare
is that the world we want to live in
where we can't call anything
by any name that has specificity or
meaning or color
or truth to it because everything has to
be clinical and we all have to be the
same
that impulse comes from an impulse
within liberalism which is to make
everybody
exactly the same so men of course men
have to become women
of course any kind of romantic
arrangement has to be exactly the same
as any other kind of romantic
arrangement
of course any kind of relationship has
to be any kind like any other kind of
relationship
of course natural institutions like the
family
or you know very basic institutions like
local government
local townships civil society of course
those have to go
away all to the to the hyper atomization
of the individual
why because then we're all more equal
but we're still differentiated right
we're differentiated on the basis of sex
most notably
so you got to get rid of that too got to
get rid of that too
and i love that it begins with fact fact
men have periods do you know what fact
means
tells you a lot about fact checking
i was discussing this the other day on
on the backstage show
over the past 10 years or so now maybe
maybe a little bit longer so
about 10 years we've had fact checks
this is relatively new
as a popular phenomenon in the media the
idea that
some politician says something you fact
check it
there are no fact checks there's no such
thing as a fact check in the in the
popular press
there are left-wing opinion columns to
varying degrees of extremism
and they call themselves fact checks
because the left refuses to acknowledge
that there is another perspective
for the left only their perspective is
legitimate other perspectives are
illegitimate for the left only their
candidates are legitimate
the other candidates are illegitimate
which is why if the other candidate wins
they don't accept the results of the
election
which they didn't do in 2016. they still
they still haven't accepted those
results and they have already said
they're not going to accept the results
of 2020.
hillary clinton said joe biden shouldn't
concede under any circumstances there is
no
fact check it's just a left-wing opinion
column
and that's that's what they're doing
here that's what the washington post is
doing the washington post this was an
amazing line
so they've got this piece insisting that
the hunter biden laptop is fake is a
trap
so is insisting that it's real the
lesson of 2016
is to be even more careful with
potential disinformation
in 2020 and here's the money line
we must treat the hunter biden leaks as
if they were a foreign intelligence
operation
even if they probably aren't
we must how do you figure how's that
we know that they're not a foreign
intelligence operation the director of
national intelligence
and the director of the fbi have told us
that it's not a foreign intelligence
operation we know it's legit
we got pictures of hunter biden on the
computer so we know it's legit we don't
think it's some photoshop artist who's
just really good
at painting lifelike images of hunter
biden in compromising positions with
various types of pipes
no it's real but they're saying we have
to pretend that they're a foreign
intelligence operation
why because washington post democracy
dies in darkness washington post fact
check why do we have to
lie about reality why do we have to
ignore reality
because when the left has to choose
between their ideology
and what they see with their own eyes
they will choose the ideology the left
we often joke about the left
as people who say who cares if it works
in practice does it work in theory
always prioritize the abstract over the
real
for the left their ideology is truer
even
than the fact of what happened you know
getting back to the story at the top of
the show
the riots are ostensibly about police
brutality we know there wasn't police
brutality in this instance that caused
the riding in philly
but the guy that that was shot had a
knife
coming at the cops clear as day
what would happen what would what you
would have happened if we followed
procedure
but whenever this happens whenever one
of these police involved killings
is justified take jacob blake jacob
blake warren after his arrest accused of
sexual assault resists arrest
reaches into a car with a weapon and the
the
complainant's kids in the car about to
drive off
finally the cops discharge their weapon
even in that case
what does the left always say they
always say well okay this instance maybe
it was justified
sometimes they'll admit that sometimes
they won't but when they do admit
they'll say okay maybe this was
justified
so maybe this specific instance wasn't
true as we're describing it
but it gets to a greater truth but it
doesn't
lies don't get too greater truth lies
are lies
what they mean by greater truth is their
ideology their ideology which continues
to be disproven time and time again
by reality so they ignore the reality
they openly they brazenly ignore the
reality they say don't admit the reality
just follow our ideology i think we
would be very foolish
as reasonable people conservatives
independents
non-leftists i think we would be very
foolish to buy into their
ideology too so let's not do it i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there